joining me now right now from the
worldwide leader in sports is one of
their lead basketball information men
love the conversations I have with Brian
Wintour's how are you Brian
so this is the real deal is this it
we're getting it this happening baskets
back I mean today look we've had a long
run a very dark day this is a good
moment I don't want to be by when I'm
grading on that moment the vote of the
owners tomorrow is not going to decide
whether or not there's NBA basketball I
know that's what it's gonna it's gonna
seem like okay what could the side of
NBA basketball is this the virus it
continues to recede or continues to
being a place we feel comfortable doing
that and I like I am right with
everybody let's talk about the 22 team
let's talk about this scenario let's
talk about that scenario but I'm already
sensing that people are forgetting the
whole reason why it's going on this way
which is they've got to be safety you
know and today for it I had its highest
number of new cases in six weeks now
that doesn't mean that everything's not
going to be a position where you feel
comfortable doing that in two months
judges so when people say is there to
the basket boy yeah I hope so I really
hope I hope that I hope that's the most
important but at least for me I'm never
gonna forget about what those what the
number one priority is here all right so
then let's linger on that issue for the
moment I'm imagining that that Adam
silver and the rest of the Board of
Governors and those that are the
stewards of the sport have agreed on a
health protocol and what based on what
you can tell does that look like you
know from what I understand it's going
to be testing every single day and I
assume that the players know what that
means
you know I think that the tests I mean
I'm not a doctor on the frontlines I
can't say but I think the test means
that you still get swab up your nose
which I I don't know if I want to do 80
consecutive days but you know for
basketball I think they're what people
are willing to do it you know Dave
McMenamin from ESPN had this story that
posted overnight about certain teams
hoping that they could if they lose
their home court
Vantage that they could maybe get some
sort of give back and they could pick
their hotel but it comes to Disney
because you know and be a player again
be 18 would rather stay at the four
seasons as opposed to the world of
massage or whatever and that the fact
that anybody Malika's even talking about
that maybe you don't want to smack my
head the point is not the quality of the
bed although obviously saying say sorry
mother Devon I said the point is the
safety idea here is that you build
something where you can keep people
protected and so all of this is going to
be part of a long meaning in other
sports and other leagues that spend 60
80 pages this is what our protocol is
this is what we're going to do every day
this is what we're going to do at the
hotel this is what we're going to do at
the arena this is what we're going to do
on the bus this is what we're going to
do at practice because what we're going
to do if somebody has symptoms this is
what we're going to do somebody actually
test positive this moon we're going to
do if somebody turns their ankle and
needs to go have an MRI this is what you
have to do if you're coming over from
Europe to fight this is what you have to
do when you're traveling into Orlando
this is what you have to do in this I
mean I can go on and on
it sounds tedious nobody wants to talk
about it but this is what this is about
this is the husband to look at about and
all of those check marks has to be there
it's not going to matter so I'm sorry
that I don't want to be debbie downer I
fail people within the league of yelled
at me for talking like this but I can't
help it it's just what I'm just just
what I have to say it well is that the
reason why July 31st has been targeted
as a start date I mean that's that's
seven weeks away and we all know seven
hours life feels like one you can pack
one year's worth of developments into
seven hours
we're talking about seven weeks now
imagining that maybe we're a full month
away for everybody to actually get
themselves to Orlando you know we're
facing potential double quarantine for
LA guys right now the law in Florida or
the rule I should say and I'm not I have
no idea whether the rules will change
right
now if you fly the Florida from New York
New Jersey or Louisiana I think
Connecticut you have two pointing for 14
days where I still be the case in in a
few weeks I don't know but if you're in
Europe like right now if you're Dallas
Mavericks can Luca dog kitchen kristaps
porzingis should do those flavors there
in europe that means you know if they're
on a plane right now to come back here
they're gonna have to according to the
laws of the country they're gonna have
to take the hotel in quarantine or their
house or whatever for two weeks they
can't start playing basketball so
another thing is that every book in the
NBA he had talked to on the on the on
the training side he's all worried about
these players who of all went cold
turkey or exactly reduce their normal
work out lows and haven't been able to
play basketball at any sort of
five-on-five way and they all were
saying you've got to have time to build
back up so in addition to building in
time to make sure that we have more
opportunity to fight the virus and
flatten the curve or just drop the curve
or what-have-you
just came to players that can help but
that we don't have guys tonight i think
i read me in the bundesliga in the
german league in the first weekend on
the first saturday and sunday they had
15 soft-tissue injuries right out of the
gate which was you know five times that
you normally would see for a midseason
game so that's one of things we're
trying to guard against which is one of
the reasons why this time open Bryan win
horse senior NBA writer of ESPN joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show so then
let's just place that aside for the
moment tomorrow at 12:30 Eastern Time
board of governors for those who may not
know who is that what does that mean how
does this go and then what it's a more
responsible way of saying owner one
person from every team will be on the
call and I'll have a vote in the boat
this is one of those things and the
other thing unlike we see in baseball
where there's a problem with the the
NBA's Union issue isn't going to be it
will probably be later for next season
because they've actually been able to
have some revenue this year but they've
kept Chris Paul who's the president and
Michelle Robinson
director Adam Silver has kept them
alongside the entire way here they're
not being surprised with any proposals
being slapped on you know their deaths
being emails and attachments they here
look at this now vote on it in fact
Michelle Roberts is so confident in the
working relationship without it's over
she said that she didn't think they'll
need to take a vote among so her you
know I believe I don't know for sure if
it's very second but it started by
understanding the Union will probably be
willing to sign off on it the both of
the Board of Governors will or Volvo
rata will ratify it and part of the
reason why rich beginning is going to
sign off on it is this plan build in a
whole bunch of game checks for players I
think that's pretty basic but I could
understand if you don't follow it if
your casual fan NBA players do not get
paid for playoff game there's a bonus
pool that they get if you get far enough
in the playoffs you get those are bonus
probably you don't get a game check so
if you advance right on to the
postseason right on to 16 team posts
even the players would lose all of those
game check 259 total games all of those
games gone by bringing back eight games
per team which will be 88 total games
they bring back a whole bunch of game
checks it will help the players retain
some money and so that's one of the
reasons why they're going to sign off on
it and then we'll get to the difficult
part which is telling all these people
all the schedule is because rich this
schedule is going to be unfair there's
13 teams in the West they're all playing
a game guess what not everybody's gonna
play the same schedule guess what Zion
Woodson is a made-for-tv player he's
probably gonna have some fights and
tougher game as a Phoenix Sun so there's
gonna be an inherent unfairness and
there's going to be fans who are going
to complain about it and teams are in
complain about it and they're all going
to be right yeah we were talking about
that before the Eastern Conference is
kind of simple you got eight games
there's nine teams everybody plays each
other once and then we're a hunk
dori right there and then you know in
the West you've got 13 teams who plays
who I mean nobody wants a piece of the
Lakers or Clippers or you can go on you
can just go down the road right there
right so certainly if you're one of
those teams trying to play in the league
stop New Orleans who is right now tied
for 10th I think there for getting back
they have the heart for they had to give
you schedule of all of those contending
teams and you've been given it yes but
they didn't cut it to 16 but you're
gonna lose your ad schedule and I know
the fine my possibility at CNRI
yesterday you know I think about the
case to be LeBron respire let's sign it
up you know you might have to play some
harder games and there's just going to
be unfairness here I mean look at
Memphis Memphis has a three and a half
game week they've played 65 games I
think they've actually play 66 it
occurred their way to the top eight over
66 games now you're telling them have to
put eight more games and continue to
earn their place and so let's say they
stay in a place over that fact attack
then they might have to play in a plan
tournament they may have to qualify for
the playoffs essentially three different
times is that fair no it's not
tough luck yeah I guess so but that said
Brian win worst here on the Rich Eisen
show prior to the pandemic breaking out
I believe your your last appearance
prior to all the craziness before the
world began to completely spin off its
axis you were talking about in your mind
what you think would be an improvement
to the NBA schedule which would be to
shorten it and have the last couple of
weeks be a tournament for the play in
for the eighth and final playoff spot
for each conference I heard that my
buddy Chris Brockman heard that were
like we like that idea
looks like your idea is going to get a
test program Brian it's just gonna be
potentially - all I wanted all
just 15 teams and mom idea was the best
way the seven teams in each conference
they move on the playoffs is normal and
they await the number eight seed and
then the 18 watney's Conference playoff
a single elimination tournament
basically eight for two you know
so you basically play the conference
tournament essentially you win three
games you don't ride a lot of NBA
basketball everything that when their
way and that's what I foresee that's not
what this is this is you know you know
you want that you want the nitty gritty
which yes the bottom line yes probably
one they had the business up to give an
excuse why they're bringing back six
extra to the reason they're bringing
back six extra teams is because they
want to play enough regular season games
and help keep enough money in the
players pocket by the way they don't
have to do it they have the right under
the CBA any but you cancel those games
and say they take your money because
there's a pen them but they need the
Union to sign off on this
they need the Union to agree to come to
Orlando they need the Union to agree to
a contract in this year so they have
players more money okay so they are
trying to figure out the way to do this
well they can't have a team that six
games back with eight games to play you
can't bring them in there and say okay
now play these games are really
important because they're not okay so
the only way you can do it is if you
create with smoke and mirrors some past
that you can at least say to the players
you have a chance to play your way and
you know with the playoffs records may
not matter like the Indiana Pacers may
come into this thing be red-hot and
what's their wait for the Eastern
Conference because it's the nature of
the uncertainty of this yes and we may
see some great stuff and it may be a
tremendous thing but the reason we're
doing this play to tournament is to just
stick the carrot out there to try to
justify why they're doing these 22 -
well I mean by the way I don't blame
them for any of that
no no I'd never it didn't damian lillard
basically say if you don't give me an
opportunity to
to play my way into the playoffs I don't
want to come and Steve Kerr's basically
saying oh we consider the season over so
this kind of checks both those boxes and
I you know and this part of the reason
why I love having you on Bryan cuz you
don't you don't mince any words here I
am kind of glass half-full I thought
some of these games you gotta just play
some games too right before you start
playing for fur right now the players
and they just got a paycheck on Monday
players are 25% of their paychecks are
being taken from them right to put into
a fund to get ready for all games and
stuff so that they don't have their
pages stuff okay if they cancel the rest
of the regular season and said no more
game check their paychecks going for a
little bebop probably around 40% okay
and keep in mind that they pay over 40
percent in taxes most of them so that
means you're going to be getting about
20% of what give your gross pay by doing
the play they're gonna potentially knock
it down to about 10 percent of your
paycheck being bought and by the way
this they're getting paid on these
contracts during November you'll ask me
if I if I have been their shoes if I had
my pay getting about 25 percent and if
we didn't play was going to be 20
percent if we play a game for a few days
and be 10 percent I know that I want my
family stock 10 percent not 40 percent
protect the money let's keep everybody
in a good friend of mine let's work
together but share the pain let's let's
have some basketball but that's why it's
all happening this is not happening
because they study that the scenario and
found out that historically teams can
come back from six games down in the
last quarter that's all just focus focus
focus
Brian when horse here for few more
minutes here on the Rich Eisen show so
Wow
how would a like you take a look at the
Eastern Conference basically it's like
can the Wizards
somehow catch
enough fire in the last eight games in
Orlando you know what about the number
80 we'll look at the number and see
because you know we care about Zion or
whatever right
the more interesting things there's one
game of the win column separating the
number four season west with the GT
columns under seventeen makes a pretty
big difference being the number
seventeen potentially claim the Nuggets
and Plan B and the number four seed you
know and in the east you know you look
at Philly right now is in the sixty you
know I don't think they want to be in
the sixty know if they want to play
Boston coming out the gate brought them
that won't play silly you know so I
think just as much as this is about the
back end and putting violin on from TV
it's some softer Devin Booker getting
some opportunity this is about the
seeding in between because the thing
about it is with no home court advantage
the matchups are going to be even more
important like you know silly twenty
nine and two at home you know if you've
got home if you're that good at home you
feel pretty good about anything now you
don't have that own portrait that fun
the matchups make a lot more have a lot
more values so to me I think where those
teams ranked in these individual
conferences and and the fight for those
students will be just as important or
even more important than the finishes
eight to get down to the to the lion how
many gyms are in Disney World I mean
there's three different facilities
there's two arenas one of them from what
I understand is mostly used for like
cheerleading and dance what I think is
going to be the main arena that they use
and then there's another arena where
you've seen games probably they play
college events they're sure
so there's two arenas and and then
there's going to be a third place where
the Convention Center will go put down
practice course because the teams are
going to practice there as well but the
interesting thing that your it will be
two games my expectation is that there
will be five or six games per day during
this period so there will be games going
on all day you know you'll be able to
watch NBA basketball two o'clock and
when we get to the playoffs they won't
be the case in the second round
but based on this date in October excuse
me um there will be NBA playoff games I
believe I was in the schedule yes there
will be NBA first-round playoff game
taking place at 2 o'clock in the
afternoon on a weekday like with
incredibly tournament it won't again it
won't be back for the second round going
forward then you can easily do it but
they're gonna have it to get done by to
play all these games and get it done by
October they're gonna have to play three
and four playoff games a day and they
can't they're not going to want to play
them concurrently too much they're going
to want to single them off and I think
you get back a new basketball yeah I
think Chris brought me you were you're
applauding off any I'm right there as
you were busy getting our stream back
online because we are at internet
problems Brian I appreciate your
patience you miss Brian basically say
let's let's let's pump the brakes a
little bit here and I don't think you're
being a Debbie Downer Bran you're you're
talking about reality and what's going
on and there's families that are gonna
come and we need to know you know the
whole logistics and on many sports
leagues are gonna be very interested in
how many hotels are being used and how
do you get players to and from stadiums
and how do you get people who are and
support roles to stay healthy and how do
you test them all and what happens if
somebody does test positive and how to
react to it I think everyone's gonna be
keenly looking at this thing and
hopefully the virus and and science and
the way that we that it progresses can
can only serve to help with more time
and we're going to learn like the NHL is
going to start one month before the NBA
and and the Premier League in England
that you've already got soccer happening
in Europe 'ln the NBA I'm gonna be
sitting there taking notes watching this
you know okay you know how was this
really good crowd noise okay what do we
do with this I mean oh you know and and
there's gonna be strange to the players
the players are gonna dress at their
hotel
these are goddess were used to walking
into arenas but $10,000 or the clothes
on that they planned out to the playoffs
three months you know they're gonna come
to the arena in their uniform and after
the game they're gonna slap on ice bags
I think and go get the bus and they're
gonna shower
back at their hotel and here's the other
thing they may not even get their rooms
clean like every day they may have
towels and sheets left outside their
room and they're gonna have to go make
their own bed and clean their own back I
mean don't be something but they're not
going to get from what I understand
they're not going to have daily service
and you know you've been to Disneyworld
RI but to give you a yes I'm sure of
course I did at the hotel the Disney
World the food is because repetitive
after a while I don't I don't know you
know I'm sure they're going to have get
some of their own chefs in there but you
know you're gonna you know they're not
going to go to them III know that it's
so it's so nice to hear Disneyworld it's
a nice thing they're not going to the
magic cane you know I think won't
mention his reporting today that they
will be allowed to play golf which is
great for the guys you play golf but
they're not I don't expect they're going
to be able to go to club on a nightly
basis you know they'll do I'm sure that
they will be just they would do some
things to help them blow off steam and
recreation but this is not gonna be so
in the summer camp no I got it I guess
so but let's let's you know for some
teams it won't be that long because
they'll play the eight regular season
games and go home and then for other
teams it won't be that long because
they'll get they'll get stomped in the
first round of the playoffs and it's a
business trip it's a business trip for
everybody to cut checks keep this gang
going get through this season and then
we'll deal with what 2020 2021 looks
like I mean I guess if they feel that
way go for it I'm not going to fight
with me on it that's fine
but this will be one of the hardest
things one of the hardest things to win
but anybody who's ever prayed for a
basketball to go through a season having
to stop down every second then having to
keep doesn't having to restart find your
edge again and dealing with not having
your facility not having your personal
chef not having your same therapy
equipment you have to deal with all that
to go through the mental
having limited access to your family and
friends you look at the mental stress of
having to be living in a hotel room for
three consecutive months because it's
going to be almost three months by the
time you quarantine train and go through
all the way of the fun was if you think
that that makes that trophy that you win
at the end lesser I can't stop you out
of it but I think it's going to make you
just a part of any other times ever been
one man Brian again I always say you're
you're the best love our chats thanks
for the time look for our call again
very soon take care of it right back
after that's Brian one horse hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here